This just in to CNN.
Taylor Dudley, a U.S.
Navy veteran
who has been detained in Russia
for nearly a year.
There's a picture of him
has now been released.
This comes after months of negot
and spearheaded
by former New Mexico
Governor Bill Richardson.
He's often been involved in nego
like this.
CNN White House reporter Natasha
joining us now with more.
As soon as Tasha,
what are the details
and what are you learning about
Yeah, so this literally just hap
moments ago.
35 year
old Taylor
Dudley, a Lansing, Michigan nati
was released
to former
Governor Bill
Richardson and his team there in
after being detained in Kalining
in April of 2022.
Now, it is not clear how Taylor
Dudley ended up in Kaliningrad.
He had been in Poland
for a music festival, we're told
And he ended up crossing the bor
And he was then detained by Russ
Border Patrol agents
there in that tiny little exclav
of Kaliningrad.
That, of course, is
Russian territory
sandwiched between Poland
and the Baltic states.
But what we know is that this ha
the process,
a process of months
of the Richardson team
trying to get him released.
And actually, what we are told
is that the former New Mexico go
who now has a nonprofit
dedicated to these kinds of host
negotiations,
did bring his case up
with the Russian officials
kind of around the same time
he was trying to negotiate
the release of Paul
Whelan, Brittney Griner and Trev
Of course,
Reed and Griner have been releas
and Paul Whalen has not.
So what we are told
is that Trevor,
that Taylor Dudley is in good he
He has been released
just moments ago to the team
that has been negotiating his re
and the Russian officials
did not demand
anything in return for his relea
So they are actually very please
about how this all went.
And, of course,
they are emphasizing at this poi
that they are still working
very hard to get Paul Whalen hom
He, of course,
remains in Russian custody.
Yes, remarkable.
No quid pro quo for this one.
Natasha thanks so much.